how dare you I'm offended you know why
they don't speak English they don't
understand they don't watch the darts
right no worm watches golf no crab
watches the rowing and goes how dare you
be so crappy
I think we obviously do know that what
they're talking about is that you're
normalizing the killing of animals and
then you know for children growing up
and hearing that language
animals kill each other yeah Matthew
help me here yeah
you're a rose of common sense
I think I think we're losing perspective
I think you know Generations in the past
are looking at us and saying what is
going on down there it's crazy I mean I
think we've we've lost all perspective
revolving